given all of that what are the polls
saying time now for our new feature it's
the daily polling pit stop to analyze
what they're suggesting george wyman's
uh with us i can tell you like the
alliteration from delta polo of course
it's great to see you thanks for joining
us where are we with the polls well it
was an interesting uh an interesting
weekend because we had polls coming out
of conservative party members of course
this crucial group that will elect the
new prime minister and the general
public
both the public generally and also
conservative supporters and it was quite
a mixed bag in terms of uh in terms of
conservative party members
we saw that liz trust was actually
growing her lead over rishi sunak and so
she's over over 60 now which is a which
is a strong lead but actually in line
with performances in previous uh
conservative membership contests where
the winners tend to win by some distance
so it's looking good for her in that
respect
but in terms of the general public the
situation was more interesting at delta
poll we ran a voting intention question
that showed that that showed that the
labour party were 11 points ahead
but when you ran hypothetical questions
asking mortifies trustworthy what if was
she soon aqua leader we saw the
situation didn't change very much okay
and if you're 60
you know 40 ahead or however you do the
math you're much better at these figures
than me at this stage of the race
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
win definitely not and what we saw
across all of the polls was high levels
of don't knows on some of the questions
for instance who would be best on the
economy you do get uh you do get strong
feelings in this case towards rishi
sunak for the general public
but you still have large numbers of
people sometimes 40 50 percent of people
saying they don't know and that's true
for the general public but it's also
true for conservative supporters
conservative voters and conservative
members and so with
so many weeks still remaining anything
could still happen because the polls are
only ever a snapshot of where we are at
the moment and both these candidates are
firstly relatively unknown still and
that's true among the general public and
true among conservative members but
they're also relatively untested and so
we've seen them now in two but not three
debates we have another debate tonight
and a following one tomorrow so this is
your um latest delta poll talk us
through it oh well uh this was the
question about who would be the uh who
would be the best prime minister and it
highlights really the problem that the
conservative face because this is uh
this is among conservative voters from
the last election so that group the
conservatives really need to hold on to
and we found that a plurality of them
across all of the different conservative
groups thought that it was right a good
thing that boris johnson resigned and
yet when given the choice between all
three candidates it was boris johnson
who was the favorite so yes they think
it was right that he leaves but they're
not convinced by his replacement and
again it illustrates that the
conservatives have some way to go and
just on that before we have a look at
the yougov poll where you used to work
of course and 97 of 2019 tory voters
rallied honesty in a leader now
that chap has been sacked twice for
lying and that's why he's lost his job
probably a third time uh yes that but
before he got the job last time 97
percent of them valid honesty as well
and so it goes to show that that people
can value these things but are sometimes
willing to compromise on their uh
compromise on their ideals to get what
they want another okay so they think
he's got the best chance of beating
labour at the next election yes that's
what they're saying let's have a look at
the yougov poll as well if we may
here we go um 56 value being able to win
the next general election as a top
priority so that's again playing into
what your poll is saying yes and second
behind uh behind winning the next
election which is of course all
important to conservative party members
was control of immigration and we saw on
the in the headlines in this morning's
newspapers how both the candidates going
very hard on that and of course they
will be doing their own polling of
members and of conservative voters as
well and so they'll know what their top
priorities are and it's no surprise to
me that that's then reflected in the
headlines and how will the polling pit
stop change depending on the hustings
and the tv debates tv debates such as
they're all important tv debates tv
debates have the potential they always
have the potential to make a difference
but after the uh shall we say rather
aggressive approach the uh certainly
these two candidates took to the
previous debates it will be interesting
to see whether they go for a more
conciliatory approach with the two
debates that are upcoming i don't
imagine they'll have an immediate impact
on the on the polling but what they may
do is put a marker down that the other
can constantly refer back to and that
cumulative effect could make a
difference and voters care about tv
debates because because it's a chance to
see these candidates really in many
cases for the first time
many people don't know who liz trusts is
many people might have heard of rishi
sunak they're really not familiar with
any of his policies or ideas so they
provide an opportunity and in many cases
the first opportunity to get themselves
in front of in front of these people in
summary um she's way ahead at the moment
but nothing to be taken for granted
in summary it's liz trusses to lose but
there is so much uh so much time left
and so many people who are undecided
that it's very much all to play for